oh hey ba welcome to another episode of
auric I can't stop won't stop can't pop
map in this [ __ ] episode we're going
to [ __ ] ride on a goddamn dinosaur
but first we need berries lots lots and
lots of berries oh god I need to kill
that thing
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god there's two
of them
Ron I'm blind I'm legally blind I have
nipple potion on me in the left corner
yes clever girl
[ __ ] he broke my new boots goddamn
nipple potions [ __ ] really lone
health team job la banda Stefani dude
out of a
[Music]
great fantastic this brings me joy where
were you when I needed you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] chicken [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is that is that a giant scorpion
[ __ ] oh my god I just [ __ ] myself okay
where did I die Oh God it's your fault
the [ __ ] is still there
what the hell ec poisoned me where's the
big dinosaur oh god oh god oh god
alright swim soon shame shame shame
shame shame I'm dead well this is a
great episode so far all that [ __ ]
scorpion [ __ ] again
[ __ ] sake I hear that [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] scariest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
no Hobbit he's still there I don't know
who raised these dinosaurs to be such
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
now ladies in bras we're going to kill a
shitload of [ __ ] dinosaurs until I get
what I want
[Music]
I'm sorry Tina why do you do this beauty
can be hide you hide any night yes and
the Paris our sail on so sex
[Applause]
now the next step is to collect a [ __ ]
ton of [ __ ] berries this will be fun
am I having fun yes I'm having fun how
much fun am I having as much as fungi
allows ah yes so much fun pressing E
looking at ax and yes so much fun
collecting berries I think we have
enough for now now we just need to find
a Paris or this is the de Bresse where
the [ __ ] are they there you are my
beautiful little [ __ ] I knew I'd find
you eventually oh my god are you gonna
run don't run I love you oh your trip
now aren't you wait he's attacking my
friend stop this nonsense great great
you ruined it you better not have
[ __ ] killed my friend
[Music]
don't run you're just making it harder
for yourself
yes did it go down oh my god Jess now
give it the berries and that would play
the waiting game okay it's taming faster
than its waking up are you enjoying it
mate got some of your favorite snacks
now go back to sleep
he's almost tamed oh oh oh
now on your my salad [ __ ] a barrage oh
yeah it's kind of slow but yeah that's
what I'm talking about
oh Ivy wanted to do this for so [ __ ]
long oh my god now I'm the king of the
jungle they said I was just a lunch lady
but look at me now I'm a lunch lady of
victory I've never felt this empowered
as a woman [ __ ] yeah alright you know
what
alright person gonna have to end that
episode that if there's anything else
you want me to do into this game let me
know and I'm gonna be a bro oh I love
this game it's so much fun to play and
I'm having a great time playing with you
bros so thank you for leaving a like if
you enjoy and I can do more that way and
that's it for now I still always bros
stay awesome
[Music]